do these notes make it plain that the
president has no brain
they mocked romney for his binders but
biden needs a sheet of reminders
on thursday day of the week dana
president biden inadvertently showed
cameras a note prepared for him by white
house staff for a meeting with wind
industry executives i think that was
swell well
the prepared instructions for joe tell
him you enter the roosevelt room and say
hello to participants
take your seat
the next one reads press enters
then you give brief comments with a
parenthetical statement reading two
minutes
press departs he's then told and then
finally you thank participants
and you depart
now thank god for the last one otherwise
he'd still be in the roosevelt room
talking to the wall
of course every president is given staff
notes but these instructions would
offend an eight-year-old
but this isn't the first time his notes
have been caught on camera just last
week our crew spotted this one during a
meeting of the press let's see if we can
read these uh let me read the first one
before approaching podium
check to see if you're wearing pants
the second one
did you go boom boom first
go make a go make a boom boom
and if necessary a pee pee
the third one if you can see that make
sure you tell jill first you bomb before
you bomb a country
unless it's canada
for nuclear war hit the right button the
red one for putting push the blue
your bunker is under the georgetown
applebee's they have your slippers in
milkshake
and last don't show notes to cameras
good advice for anyone so what gives joe
hey hey come on come on man look look
everybody keeps notes right
you know who else kept notes
einstein
and lincoln
remember that four score and seven years
ago today he kept he kept looking down
you're like
i was there i remember it
now
i
have got one more thing that i
want to say right
you lean in and do the creepy whisper
thing that you are known for we're gonna
build back better
so cat
i do have to uh i would be a hypocrite
if i didn't point out that i have notes
uh but they're very complicated my notes
are very the complicated sections of
text yeah read up rita read a piece
cat i would be a hypocrite
i didn't point out that my notes
were you large complicated sections of
text see that yeah i just read that
do you think that this will force him to
have more complex notes like that'll be
their thing like oh we're in trouble we
need more we in case we get caught again
let's have like some complex notes no
because i think that if you
need a sheet like that
then probably a sheet like that is not
going to be enough to help you
um
because like what if he forgets what
things he did and didn't do yet like
he's not even checking it off how what
if he's like did i take my seat or not
you know
i mean
we're talking
about somebody who has gotten what state
he is in wrong several times yeah he
needs to cross the thing yeah he needs
to i would advise him to bring a pen
when he sits down okay i am sitting yes
and then the next thing is cross it off
yeah it's the crosstalk and you have to
have the thing that says cross the cross
off yeah
it could go on forever it could go on
forever liz these are this it's not a
cheat sheet this is like
basic instructions for like inserting
batteries into a remote control
it's like an ikea you know the little
sheet you get with the ikea dresser that
you never put together liz yeah the line
that really struck to me was you take
your scene
right like
is he a seat stealer
is hunter
stealing seats i don't know and then it
was like
and then i was looking for the line make
sure this car doesn't face the front
yeah you know and so
last week or the earlier this week he he
was asked what about the china turrets
tariffs he said we haven't made up my
mind yet
is he is he
is he the manchurian candidate
who's running his brain who's who's in
charge
it's like that weird uh pixar movie
remember where all the kid had all those
emotions in her head yeah i can't
remember it
do the voters feel scammed thank you do
the voters feel scammed yeah well that's
joey he doesn't have stolen valor he has
stolen cognition
no he doesn't he hasn't stolen anything
he's not faking anything like he's not
he's not fooling anyone
the this little sheet itself not a big
deal but this sheet is a huge story in
the context of the man saying i've got
one word for this country i'll film him
you know it's like
what do we do with that we look at that
and we go if that were anyone else in
any other setting we're concerned but
there's this like righteous indignation
among democrats we're not allowed to
question his acuity we're not calling
him crazy we're not diagnosing him with
dementia we're saying mr president
complete a sentence you know
once
please and when it doesn't happen over
and over again and then you pile on top
of that a cheat sheet that tells you
pretty basic things like listen i worked
for generals they get cheat sheets like
this that are almost as dumbed down but
in the marine corps we make fun of what
we're doing we're going to break it down
barney style we're going to make this so
easy that any idiot in the world can do
it
i give you a cheat sheet for the
president there you go dana were bush's
notes like this president bush or no not
really they were more like who's next
kitty everybody um and now you would
have like some notes uh but
this this was extremely specific and you
do wonder does he actually need that or
is the staff just like trying to figure
out something to do so that they can
justify their existence like i'm gonna
make the card today right and i'm gonna
i need eight points so i'm going to make
sure all those eight points but i did
want to point out at the top of the card
it says offshore wind drop by sequence
of events
at the very same time this meeting was
happening
at the white house
he sent all the oil executives to down
the street to meet with the secretary of
energy at the exact same time because he
didn't want to meet with them but he
would meet with the wind guys at the
white house oh that's amazing well he
has something in common with the wind
guys produces
produces a lot of it
both ends
[Laughter]
possible
up next if you're hot to trot should you
get your monkey pox shot hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else